[Music]
now I know what you're thinking how the
heck does a 52 year old over the hill
milkshake machine salesman build a fast
food Empire with 1600 restaurants in 50
states five foreign countries with an
annual revenue of in the neighborhood of
700 million dollars
McDonald's operators have had enough for
decades they've put up with the
McDonald's anti-franchisee policies and
aggressive corporate politics just to
have a chance at the growing a thriving
restaurant but the more time they put in
the more they realize that this deal is
far more favorable for McDonald's the
average franchisee pulls in 150 000 per
year from each restaurant which sounds
great Until you realize you have to
invest one to 2.2 million dollars to get
your hands on a location in other words
operators are running a full restaurant
business just to earn a 10 return on
their investment instead of putting in
all this effort into Running a
Restaurant operators could just invest
their money into the S P 500 and earn
comparable returns with absolutely no
effort this is only made worse by the
fact that as a franchisee you're not
even building up your own brand you're
building up McDonald's brand with just
doing better than ever you know how
there's all this fear about recessions
layoffs bank failures interest rates and
whatnot well despite all that turmoil
McDonald's is doing better than ever
they're one of the only companies whose
stock is at near all-time high levels
giving them a valuation of is just under
200 billion dollars a similar story can
be seen with their net income as well in
the last 12 month period McDonald's
profited just over 6 billion dollars if
we divide that amongst their 38 000
locations we get an average income per
store of 162 thousand dollars or even
more than the average franchisee given
McDonald's brand image it's not
surprising that they're able to charge
such a premium but more franchisees than
ever are starting to question whether
all of this is even worth it and for
many of them the answer is no in 2021 a
record at 13 of franchise own locations
changed hands for perspective only six
percent of Burger King franchise
locations changed hands during the same
time period if we zoom out a little it
just looks even worse for McDonald's
between 2019 and 2022 28 of McDonald's
locations were either closed or sold off
and according to operators it's only
getting worse there was apparently a
line to get out the door so here's why
McDonald's operators are leaving in
droves and the frightening implications
for McDonald's
McDonald's likes to write off The Exodus
as simply pent-up demand from the
pandemic but in reality there was a
pivotal event in 2018 remodels this
marked the biggest remodel in the
company's history in decades and it was
required McDonald's wanted a new
furniture new Decor remodeled counters
exterior redesigns digital kiosks and
reimagined drive-through Lanes even if
you only go to McDonald's on an
occasional basis I'm sure you've noticed
these changes and honestly they're
pretty nice but they were also quite a
burden for franchise owners McDonald's
offered to pay 55 of the renovation
expenses for the affected 14 000 us
restaurants which came out to a total of
six billion dollars
this means that the average cost to
renovate each store was a whopping 779
000 out of which operators were
responsible for 350 000 and that's just
the average for older more outdated
stores through renovation expenses were
probably closer to a million dollars if
not over which pushes up the operated
contribution to nearly half a million
this is made even worse by the fact that
the stores that are most likely to be
outdated and run down are the ones that
aren't performing well in other words
the stores that are performing the worst
would likely have to pay the highest
bill for forty percent of operators this
was completely unfeasible as the remodel
experience would put them in danger of
not having their leases renewed based on
McDonald's own Financial requirements
though McDonald's does dispute this
number for obvious reasons operators
were triggered
in fact when asked to rate the
relationship with McDonald's from a
scale of one to five the average
operator gave a rating of
1.19 and that was in April of 2022. this
was the third worst rating in the
service history and the two times that
it was worse were both during the height
of the remodels all of this tension
would lead to the creation of basically
a franchisee Union named the national
Owners Association in 2018 which was the
first of its kind in the company's
history the association has been trying
to Advocate on behalf of operators but
it doesn't seem like they've been able
to make much tangible progress in fact
McDonald's has not only not backed off
but they've tried to offload even more
of the remodel expenses onto operators
the most notable example of this was a
new technology fee that McDonald's
implemented in late 2020. apparently
McDonald's was racking up too much debt
so they decided to charge operators a 70
million technology fee operators would
end up suing McDonald's but even this
didn't eliminate the fee though it did
reduce it by 60 percent it seems that
McDonald's has gotten into a habit of
prioritizing and consumers and
shareholders over everything else which
isn't a bad thing in itself the reason
that it's bad in McDonald's case is that
they're doing it at the cost of
operators which was not exactly a very
smart move long term given that 93 of
your locations are operated by
independent business owners but
expensive remodels and annoying
technology fees are just the tip of the
iceberg the truth is that the entire
partnership between operators and the
McDonald's is just a facade
when you think McDonald's we all think
of burgers fries creepy clowns and big
golden arches but what if I told you
that McDonald's doesn't actually make
money from any of this well these are
what US consumers associate with
McDonald's the reality is that we're not
even the real end consumer of McDonald's
the real and the consumer is actually
operators and if you don't believe me
just take it from McDonald's former CFO
himself we are not technically in the
food business we are in the real estate
business the only reason we sell 15 cent
hamburgers is because they are the
greatest producer of revenue from which
our tenants can pay us our rent this
might be confusing because it's been
ingrained in all of our minds that
McDonald's is a fast food company but in
reality McDonald's figured that that
wasn't all that lucrative decades ago I
mean just think about it even if you
sell billions of burgers every a year if
you only make 10 or 20 cents on each
Burger it's not gonna be that much money
on a company skill if you own the lands
of tens of thousands of the most
desirable locations in the world and the
charge operators massive leases though
well now you're talking this isn't
magnitudes more profitable than selling
burgers and it's evident in McDonald's
market cap they're worth over four times
more than the second largest restaurant
chain at Chipotle and they're worth
almost 20 times more than Domino's this
isn't to say that McDonald's is 20 times
more popular than dominoes or that they
sell 20 times more food but it does mean
that their business is 20 times more
attractive for investors while this
model is brilliant for investors it
hasn't been all that friendly for
operators especially over the past few
years because of the real estate boom
right at the beginning of the pandemic
the FED cut interest rates to zero
percent which led to real estate across
the country going absolutely wild and a
given that McDonald's is a real estate
business I don't think you'd be
surprised to see that McDonald total
assets also went wild but this didn't
exactly sit well with operators here
they were struggling to pay cashiers and
the burger flippers minimum wage during
one of the worst Hospitality crises ever
while McDonald's was doing better than
ever of course you can argue that all of
this is in the fine print and that
operators should look into all aspects
of the franchise before signing and that
is true but with that being said it's
also natural for people to get mad in
such a situation when you sign up for a
franchise you expect to be partners with
their company you expect to share their
good times and the bad times but in
McDonald's case it seems like the
partnership is cleverly structured such
that all of the risk of running a low
margin fast food business lies on the
operator and for many operators the
pandemic was the eye opener they needed
to see the partnership for what it
really was and now that things have
finally stabilized on their side as well
they want out
if these one-sided policies weren't a
good enough reason to leave yet another
reason to leave is that modern
Generations aren't as eager to get into
the fast food business traditionally
many McDonald's locations are run almost
like a family business
a family might own a few locations in
their Hometown and they pass it down a
generation after generation but for the
first time the new generation doesn't
want it it's not just that McDonald's
franchisee policies aren't that great
but also that there is a way more
opportunities out there thanks to the
internet if you're gonna go down deep
partner with a big company approach why
partner with a fast food company when
you can partner with a tech company you
can become a Google AdWords partner or a
YouTube Partner or an Amazon affiliate
marketer or an FBA seller the options
are basically endless online also you
don't even have to go down the
entrepreneurial route in the Western
World you don't have to run a business
to make 150 000 per year there's plenty
of jobs that pay the same or more
without the stress of running a full-on
restaurant so naturally despite putting
in decades into their business many
families want out these families would
of course prefer an amicable split but
McDonald's is making this rather
difficult as well first of all they
don't even question you about why you're
leaving which is quite surprising I mean
if you're trying to cancel a simple cell
phone Planet you'll run into four sales
reps asking you why you're leaving and
trying to convince you to stay but at
McDonald's not a single person at ask
operators why they're leaving them which
simply strengthens the idea that they
don't really care about their operators
that's quite a shame but the bigger
disappointment for many operators is
that they don't even get to choose who
they hand off their location to if you
spend it 30 40 50 years building up a
location it would make sense that you
want to hand off the location to someone
you know and trust but McDonald's is
often blocking this all right you see on
paper they have the right to First
refusal traditionally this wasn't
enforced very strictly but given that
many operators are starting to take a
stand against McDonald's MC has resorted
to leveraging this right more
aggressively this way they can route the
stores to more passive investor
operators but that just makes the
situation worse for all of the remaining
everyday operators all of this is
leading to operators not even missing
the business that they worked on for
decades and as more random or operators
start feeling this way the McDonald's
operator Exodus is only gonna get worse
for franchises It's usually the
operators that can make or break the
business McDonald's has cleverly
structured their business to minimize
the impacts from unhappy operators but
even this will only Shield them so much
at the end of the day if operators drop
the ball on one of these stores people
will have a worse experience at
McDonald's and they will come less often
eventually this would lead to locations
becoming unprofitable meaning that
operators won't be able to pay
McDonald's their Cash Cow lease payments
and if a location is already performing
poorly it's just gonna be even harder to
bring in another operator and try to
turn things around especially if that
operator isn't all that happy to be
there either McDonald's isn't quite at
that point yet but given that 28 of
stores were sold off or shut down within
the past couple of years it won't take
long for things to get that bad if
McDonald's doesn't take any action so I
think think it's in McDonald's best
interest to get on the good side of your
operators as soon as possible unless
they want to continue facing this Mass
Exodus and ruin her business in a record
time but that's just what I think do you
like McDonald's comment that down below
also drop a like if you think that
McDonald's operator policies are
brilliant but also terrible and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community to suggest with your video
ideas and the considers of copying to
see more questions are logically
answered but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]